i mean if you want my two cents she
doesn't and i'm sorry you are are you
family member or it's complicated i'm
her roommate now and he's a terrible
communicator and he's really i don't
know if there's a medication you could
give to nick that would help me be less
stressed or except when i'm around
my boyfriend and i broke up right before
quarantine started kick him out you have
to get him out of there i can't kick him
out where's he gonna go he has like 12
so i don't have a job it's like i'm
working for you living in this apartment
just by it's not new i'm reading for
like weird foreign animated shows you
know what eddie murphy did shrek yep he
got paid millions of dollars exactly but
you not eddie murphy
i gotta get out of there man i just
can't be around her anymore we've been
trying to create really strict
boundaries you know he's in the other
room we hardly interact
i think the best way to get over
somebody is just move on to the next
thing you know it really lights a fire
under me though there's this guy trying
to get with my ex-girlfriend yeah there
were parts of it where we broke the
social distancing rules do you mind
stepping back a little bit we're trying
to keep a six foot distance thing going
on here oh no we're we're good i'm six
three so i know what i'm six feet long
yeah
you never take responsibility for
yourself and you act like you don't even
care about me half the time i don't
think you want to get back together i
think you're just too lazy to move out
and go start your own life i'm not
trying to change anything with us for a
while it was like i love you so much
that it's impossible to not hit you
it's gonna be dope man i'm super excited
i'm like i don't know what to do how i
feel
we maybe did have sex but other on the
other hand maybe we didn't i don't know
what that means
[Music]